auf einem rad die bergwacht ein kleines
abenteuer aber möglich die
einradfahrerin stephanie dietze hat
dafür jahrelang trainiert und sich mit
viel mut und einer großen portion
verrücktheit einen traum erfüllt immer
wieder eine neue herausforderung ist es
wird immer immer noch ein bisschen
schwerer umso mehr man macht und weil es
natürlich unglaublich viel spaß macht
blaue flecken sind beim mountain juni
cycling oder downhill fahren wie sich
dieser extremsportart nennt programmiert
stephanie dietze nimmt es gelassen
das wird einfach dazu vor zwei jahren
ist sie von wien nach berlin umgezogen
eine stadt die sehr flach ist aber auch
der drachenberg mit seinen 99 metern
höhe hat seine reize
beim damen geht es darum eine möglichst
steile strecke so runter zu fahren dass
man nicht fällt man fällt recht auf dem
einrad fahren und dass es die
herausforderung dass man über muscheln
steine fährt und dass so ein berechnet
dass man in einem durchfahren kann
zürich seit 18 jahren trainiert
stephanie dietze bis zu dreimal pro
woche
angefangen hat alles in einem verein in
ihrem heimatort rodgau bei frankfurt als
ihre freundinnen aufhörten machte sie
weiter
das schwierigste sei nicht aufzugeben
sagte 26 jährige denn bis man mit dem
einrad ein wenig geradeaus fahren kann
vergehen oft wochen
auch von einer vergessen und einfach zu
fahren ist ein ganz tolles gefühl mal so
man fühlt sich so ein bisschen als ob
man die schwerkraft austrickst weil es
eigentlich fast unmöglich ist auf so
einem kleinen punkt zu balancieren
und wenn man das dann doch machen und
dann auch noch sogar irgendwelche
schweren wege mit steinen und wurzeln
dass das ein ganz tolles gefühl von
freiheit
im vergangenen jahr setzte sich
stephanie dietze zusammen mit dem
vierfachen einrad weltmeister lutz
eichholz ein außergewöhnliches ziel
einen 3000 meter hohen gipfel in den
dolomiten zu befahren
zwei tage waren sie insgesamt unterwegs
ein jahr zuvor überquerten sie zu dritt
die alpen vom bayerischen füssen bis
nach südtirol
es macht schon spaß über höhere berge zu
erklimmen und hohe hinauszugehen
einfach weil sich landschaft auch
verändert also ab 3000 meter ist es
schon hochalpines gelände
es würde mich schon auch weizen dann
noch höher hinaus geht also irgendwie
4000 meter vielleicht zu erreichen was
natürlich auch gleichzeitig sehr
gefährlich wird aber sehr schön heraus
warum kunststücke auf dem einrad
damit hat stephanie dietze angefangen
hierfür benutzt sie ein leichteres
kleines rad ihr geschick bescherte ihr
zwei mal den weltmeistertitel im park
freestyle
sie sieht riecht kann man nur wenn man
sie mehrere hundert male oder 1000
normale gegen kat und das schöne am
freestyle fahren ist dass ich mich fühle
als ob ich schwebe also ich fahre ihn
trägt so dass es ganz flüssig aussieht
und ganz leicht auch geht und welche
über den boden fasst schwebe ist es ein
ganz tolles gefühl
seit vier jahren klettert die
einradfahrerin regelmäßig sie fordert
sich gerne selbst heraus geht an grenzen
und will so auch ihre ängste überlisten
das für mich ein ganz toller ausgleich
zum einradfahren
ich kann zwar jemand gleich anbringen
aber sind ganz andere muskeln wie ich
beantworten die so auch noch trainieren
kann und es ist hier eine andere
verbindung weil ich hier meine
höhenangst überwinden muss und schauen
musste sich ab und meine muskeln nicht
mehr wollen trotzdem noch weiter nach
oben gehen
disziplin ist alles beim einradfahren
für stephanie dietze selbstverständlich
ihr rad ist ihr ständiger begleiter auch
aufweisen zurzeit träumt sie davon
einmal die berühmten autobauers in
kanada oder den usa mit dem einrad zu
durchqueren